hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the differences between
bacteriostatic and bactericidal drugs so
first let's talk about bactericidal
bactericidal refers to an antibiotic
that actually kills the bacteria and you
can tell that by this route here Seidel
things like homicide murder so it's for
killing killing the bacteria
specifically without help from the
patient's immune system so it does not
require the patient's immune system to
do anything that can kill the bacteria
by itself so that's bactericidal
examples of bactericidal drugs include
beta-lactam drugs like penicillin as
well as think of mice in another kind of
common antibiotic now upon removal
meaning that when the patient stops
taking the bactericidal drug there will
be no more growth and that's because as
long as they took it for a long enough
period of time all of the bacteria that
it was targeting should have died until
there should not be any re-establishment
of infection suspect TerraCycle now I'll
talk about bacteriostatic this is where
the antibiotic prevents the
multiplication or the growth of the
bacteria and the goal here is that
bacteriostatic drugs they prevent the
bacteria from being able to multiply and
divide and become more numerous and this
allows the patient's immune system to
kill the bacteria so the bacteria sent
drugs just kind of slow things down
depress this multiplication process in
order for the immune system to get ahead
of the infection and take care of it
examples of bacteriostatic drugs include
chloramphenicol and tetracycline and
upon removal if there are still bacteria
around that have not been taken care of
by DME
system if a bacteriostatic drug is
removed then growth can resume let's
take a look up here at this graph just
for an example of this on the y axis we
have the number of cells it's a
logarithmic scale on the x axis we have
time and what I've drawn here is this
dark solid line is representing a
bacteriostatic drugs whereas the dashed
line is representing a bactericidal drug
and so what this shows is if you have
bacteria that you inoculate into a test
tube of growth media they will begin to
increase in number and then if you add a
drug if it's a bacteriostatic drug that
will prevent multiplication of the
bacteria without killing them if it's a
bactericidal drug it will actually kill
them causing the bacterial numbers to
fall down then if in the test tube you
remove the drug if it was a bactericidal
drug there would be no additional growth
all the bacteria are dead if it is a
bacteriostatic drug growth can then
resume for that bacteria so this is sort
of a hypothetical example in a test tube
without the patient's immune system when
actually being used these different
drugs to treat patients their immune
system is also a major player in the
process let's also talk about some
similar classes of drugs for treating
other kinds of pathogens so for example
there are different kinds of fungicidal
drugs and fungus static drugs used for
treating fungi
and again fungicidal kills the fungal
cells and just static just prevents
their growth so that the immune system
can take care of the problem there's
also for treating parasites we have
parents at a site old versus Paris at a
static again kills the parasite prevents
the parasite from multiplying and then
for treating viruses again there are
some antiviral medications that are by
recital actually sort of terminate the
virus make it completely unfunctional
even if it were removed and then virus
that it's something that just prevents
the replication of the viruses so the
immune system can come in and take care
of the rest
now there are some caveats meaning that
it's not always this cut-and-dry we
can't always say well all of these drugs
are bacteriostatic and all of these
drugs are bactericidal and that's
because of a few things
so some drugs are actually
bacteriostatic at lower concentrations
but if they are applied in a high enough
concentration than their bactericidal so
the concentration at which the drug is
administered matters also some drugs are
bacteriostatic against certain species
but back to recital against others and
that has to do with different bacteria
having different kinds of defenses to
certain antibiotics and so some of these
drugs are only bacteriostatic in some
species but can outright kill other
species of bacteria also and I think
this is pretty cool some bacteria static
drugs are bactericidal when they're
administered together this is an example
of synergism
so it's a synergistic effect meaning
that when you take a drug like
sulfamethoxazole and combine it with
trimethoprim maybe these are both
bacteriostatic if they're used
when they're applied together that kind
of one-two punch is actually
bactericidal enough to kill the
bacterial cells if you're interested in
learning a little bit more I have a
video on bacterial growth curve and
binary fission that will tell you about
how bacteria grow and multiply if you're
interested also in the topic of
antibiotic resistance how some bacteria
have become resistant to many of our
frontline antibiotics and you can also
check out my video on antibiotic
resistant bacteria a bit for today
thanks for watching biology professor